So having talked about the vision and the practical
implementation details of active networks, let's talk about the
pros and cons. The pro is something that we
have been stressing all along and that is the flexibility
from the point if you have an application perspective
that fact that you can ignore the physical layout
of the network and slap on your own visualization
of what you want to accomplish for your netowork flow.
On top of the physical infrastructure is
the key selling point for active networks. But
this selling point comes at the cost of perhaps certain cons. What are all the
cons? Well, one concern could be protection threats. What I mean by that is that
eroding infrastructures carrying network flows. Not really mine
but yours and the third person and so
on and so forth. And just like in an
operating system when we have a process, we want to make
sure that that process is not doing anything malicious
to other processes in the same node. Same way, my
network flow should not do anything that is detrimental
to your network flow on the internet. So that's what
we mean by protection threats. So there are some
safeguards in the ANTS toolkit to address these protection threats.
The first is the run time safety of ANTS
program that is running on a router node. And
the way they ensure that is by first of
all implementing ANTS itself in Java and using Java
sandboxing technique on the router node, so that anything
that a router code is doing for capsule processing
Is limited to the Java's hand box that is
executing in. And so, it cannot effect the flows
of other network flows that are flowing through
the same routing fabric. That's the first thing. The
2nd protection thread is whether there could be
code spoofing that can happen. We are talking about
cold being injected into the router, and of
course there was a good reason for doing that,
that I wanted a certain behavior to be
observed by the network routers, in response to packets
flowing through the network that belongs to me. But
I want to be sure that the code that is
being executed is the code that I wrote not
some malicious code that is being spoofed to that node.
Well here, here the safeguard is making sure that
you have a robust, a robust fingerprint associated with the
code. And so what you do is you generate
a tight field for the capsule that is a crytographically
strong finger print of the original code. And it
always matching when you get the code from a
previous known In response to your requst, you're goint
to compute the fingerprint once more. Check it against the
fingerprint that is contained in the capsule, ensure that
there is no code spoofing happening. That's how you can
overcome this protection threat. And the third concern can
be integrity of the soft state. And what I mean
by that is, the soft store that's available
at an ordered node is limited in size, and
you don't want any particular network flow to
arbitrarily consume all of the soft state. And yet
again, there is a restricted API that is
provided in ANTS, that's the safeguard. For this protection
threat. So these protection threats are concerns. But at
least in the ANTS tool kit, they offer solutions
to ensure that these protection threats are
not show stoppers for active networks. The second
concern that one might have is Resource
Management threats. Now what I mean by that
is Because we are executing code at a router, the result of that code execution
could be that I proliferate packets in the
internet. I'll give you an example of resending
a message to my siblings I send one message,
and at some point That one message becomes n
message. So in some sense, we can start flooding
the network with capsule processing. Is that a threat?
Well it is, but internet is already susceptible to
this kind of resource management threat and yes capsule
adds to it, but it is not anything new
that it is adding in terms of resource management threat.
On the other hand, we can ask the question at
each node is it going to consume more resources than
it should. And this again comes back to the safegaurd
that they have in the ANTS toolkit that the api is
a restricted api and therefore the amount of resources that
you can consume at a node It's fairly restricted, so
there is sort of a mixed answer to this resource
management concern. At a given node, the resource management concern doesn't
quite exist so long as you adhere to the restricted API of ANTS. And the second
concern that the capsules may flood the network
can happen, but it already happens, we all
experience spam on The internet so this is not adding any new problem but it is
perhaps exasterbating an existing problem. So having looked
at division and looking at division and the practicality
of active networks, time for a quiz.